[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend der
deutschlandpakt sei erledigt cduf
Friedrich MZ Klang da heute Vormittag
ziemlich apodiktisch in seinem Urteil
und ein bisschen reibt man sich da schon
die Augen schließlich wurde da gestern
insgesamt 17 Stunden verhandelt in
großen runden mit vielen gewichtigen
unionsministerpräsidenten und er selbst
hatte zuvor ja seine eigenen kleinen
migrationsgipfel mit dem Kanzler gehabt
und jetzt soll das alles für die Katz
gewesen sein eine der Fragen die ich
gleich an einen der Teilnehmer Stelle
nordrin-westfalens Ministerpräsident
Hendrik wüst der in diesem
Verhandlungsmarathon eine ganz eigene
Rolle spielte zuvor zeichnet Thomas
reicher nach wie und zu welchen
Ergebnissen man kam und wie sie heute
bei Tageslicht bewertet
werden die Schritte langsam die Minen
erschöpft es ist schließlich 2:45 Uhr
soangee Verhandlungen gibt es auch in
Berlin nur selten und statt eines
zwischendurch mal drohenden eklar steht
am Ende immerhin eine Einigung ich will
nicht zu große Worte ergreifen aber doch
sagen dass ich glaube dass das hier ein
sehr historischer Moment ist in dem wir
hier sitzen auch die unionszeite der
Ministerpräsidenten ist am frühen Morgen
nach insgesamt fast 17 Stunden zähen
Ringens erstmal ganz
zufrieden ich bin der festen Überzeugung
dass wir einen ich betone das Schritt in
die richtige Richtung heute gemacht
haben tatsächlich ist Scholz der Union
entgegengekommen z.B bei der Auslagerung
von Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten dem
sogenannten Ruanda Modell das nun
geprüft werden soll und der Bund gibt
mehr Geld an Länder und Kommunen pro
Asylbewerber gibt es 7500 € außerdem
eine Abschlagszahlung über 1,75
Milliarden es wären insgesamt rund 3,5
Milliarden Euro an Entlastung für Länder
und Kommunen weit mehr als der Bund
ursprünglich wollte ich wünsche mir sehr
dass das was heute gelungen ist
gemeinsam mit der
Bundesregierung ergänzt wird und dann
eben auch komplettiert wird durch eine
Verständigung hier in Berlin zwischen
Bundesregierung und Union Friedrich Merz
aber den es für diese Verständigung
braucht war nicht dabei im Kanzleramt
und genau das scheint das Problem denn
er sieht am Morgen die Ergebnisse
deutlich kritischer als die meisten
unionsländerchefs in der Nacht und nicht
nur das das was der Bundeskanzler heute
als historisch bezeichnet hat betrachte
ich zunächst einmal als den vorläufigen
Endpunkt der gemeinsamen Gespräche zur
Migrationspolitik von dem
deutschlandpakt den der Bundeskanzler am
seember zum Thema Migration im Deutschen
Bundestag einmal angekündigt hat sind
wir nach den Beschlüssen der vergangenen
Nacht jedenfalls weit entfernt März war
di Tage zuvor selbst im Kanzleramt da
galt sie noch die Idee eines
deutschlandpakts zur Migration das
Gespräch an jenem Freitag fand MZ sehr
gut die Einigung jetzt nicht
zufriedenstellend weil er selbst daran
nicht beteiligt war weil er sich
ausgebotet fühlt nach seinem
kanzlergespräch nicht die da irgendwie
gegeben haben aber es hat die
Verhandlung nicht erleichtert dass
eigentlich alle nicht so genau wussten
was eigentlich Grundlage dieser
Gespräche ist es wirkt als sein sich
märz und mächtige länderschefs der Union
nicht einig wer das Sagen hat bei
Verhandlungen mit der Ampel dabei sind
sie alle gefragt die
migrationsbeschlüsse sollen schnell
gesetzt werden in Bundestag und
Bundesrat immerhin eine
Verhandlungssache aus der Nacht ist auch
am Tag danach unstrittig das 49 € Ticket
soll es auch im nächsten Jahr geben dann
begrüße ich den Ministerpräsidenten von
Nordrein-Westfalen guten Abend Herr wüst
schön guten aben Frau slomker wir haben
es eben gehört das ist ja ein sehr
negatives Urteil dass die Parteispitze
die CDU Parteispitze Herr März da trifft
über die Ergebnisse an denen sie nun
sehr intensiv beteiligt waren sehen Sie
das genauso
negativ wir müssen dieses Ergebnis der
Nacht Messen an dem was wir erreichen
müssen wir müssen erreichen irreguläre
Migration zu beenden dazu brauchen wir
eine W in der Asylpolitik damit wir noch
den Menschen gerecht werden können die
unsere Hilfe wirklich brauchen und
gemessen daran ist das ein Schritt aber
sicherlich nicht das letzte Wort in
dieser Debatte und vieles was wir
verabredet haben muss jetzt auch erstmal
umgesetzt werden und dazu brauche es den
Deutschen Bundestag ich finde es gut
wenn die Bundesregierung weiter versucht
auch die Union ins Boot zu kriegen aber
dazu wird es Gespräche brauchen was ja
so ein bisschen komisch war dass Herr
güntherorf aus steswig holstand sagte
man habe eigentlich gar nicht so genau
gewusst was Herr Herr märz mit dem
Kanzler vorher besprochen hätte und das
hätte sich doch erschwerend auf die
Verhandlungen ausgewirkt waren sie da
besser
informiert na ich die können ja
miteinander sprechen das ist doch auch
wichtig wenn man das Ziel hat wirklich
ein fundamentale Veränderung in einem so
wichtigen Politikfeld zu machen ist es
doch gut wenn eine oppositions
buundestagsfraktion nicht nur
fundamental Opposition macht sondern
auch zu Gesprächen bereit ist und da
muss man auch mal vertraulich reden
können mhm D haben sie heute Vormittag
gesagt also das ist nicht der große Wurf
so klang sie jetzt eben auch welcher
Punkt wäre denn wichtig gewesen damit es
zumindestens so ein mittelgroßer Wurf
gewesen wäre na wenn Sie das Ergebnis
der Nacht anschauen sind eine Menge
Prüfaufträge äh drin und wir haben
leider unsere Erfahrung gemacht wir
haben im im Mai schon Dinge verabredet
die sind bis heute nicht äh umgesetzt
deswegen ist Umsetzung äh wichtig einige
Punkte waren nicht einigungsfähig z.B
dass wir Menschen die aus Ländern kommen
aus denen man in der Regel kaum eine
Chance hat ein Asylrecht zu bekommen
unter 5% dass wir dafür für schnellere
Verfahren hinkriegen das sind 6 000
Menschen die zwischen Baum und Borke
sind viele Jahre weil die Verfahren so
lange dauern die sind da aber sie können
eigentlich nicht bleiben das wäre gut
gewesen da was zu machen
die Frage was ist mit immer wieder
wiederholten
asylantragstellungen auch da konnten wir
uns nicht einigen es gibt ein paar
andere Punkte auch noch wir haben was
erreicht ja aber das ist noch nicht die
Wende die wir brauchen um die Zahlen
runterzukriegen derjenigen die kein
Recht haben hier zu sein wir wollen uns
ja gut um die kümmern die ein Recht
haben hier zu sein darum geht's aber
dazu müssen weniger kommen die kein
Recht haben hier zu sein das Ziel haben
zumindestens alle aber vielleicht lief
ihn ja auch ein bisschen die Zeit davon
weil sie mit einem ganz neuen Vorstoß
kamen den eigentlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt
keiner auf dem Zettel hatte und dann war
so viel Zeit darüber zu diskutieren dass
man über anderes da nicht mehr so
intensiv reden konnte war das im
Nachhinein betrachtet so richtig klug
mit diesem Ruanda Modell so Holter die
Polter um die Ecke zu kommen na ja
Holter die Polter ist Teil von
Beschlussfassung der SPD
Bundestagsfraktion
SPD Sachen die hatten die Länder
miteinander besprochen und sie hatten
sich schon alle abgestimmt über welche
Punkte es gehen sollte und dann waren da
die a-länder und die b-länder und großes
Staunen bei den SPD geführten Ländern
nein wir haben vor drei Wochen eine
jahresmpk gehabt und wir haben gestern
wieder neu vorbereitet wir haben gestern
wieder vorbereitungsrunden gehabt und da
gibt es immer die Möglichkeit auch
Vorschläge einzubringen das haben wir
gemacht gemeinsam als b-länder übrigens
CDU CSU und das grünregierte
BadenWürttemberg äh zusammen ähm da
sollte dann blockiert werden mit der
parteipolitischen Karte seitens der SPD
Länder es ist nicht die Zeit für
Parteipolitik dazu sind die
Herausforderung viel zu groß und
deswegen ist es auch gut dass es jetzt
im Abschlusspapier äh drin ist denn so
schlimm kann es nicht gewesen sein die
Bundesregierung hat ja dann zugestimmt
dass das geprüft werden soll sie hätten
natürlich wenn es nicht um Parteipolitik
geht sondern wirklich darum etwas
gemeinsam auf die Beine zu bekommen
hätten sie natürlich die a-länder auch
mal vorher informieren können und sagen
Leute wir wir wollen auch dass über
dieses Ruanda Modell gesprochen wird
macht euch mal gedanken dazu hätte man
machen können es ist ja jetzt nichts
neues das ist ja bekannt ist ja seit
Wochen in der Debatte und wir haben ja
unsere vorbereitungsrunden und da haben
wir es ja auch diskutiert mhm W man sich
das Modell jetzt mal selbst anguckt das
ist relativ schwierig durchzusetzen also
auch ein CDU Bundeskanzler würde
wahrscheinlich nicht direkt eine
Handvoll afrikanischer Länder finden die
bereit sind und auch geeignet sind
daitzumachen absolut richtig aber Frau
slomker was ist die Alternative dass wir
weiter dem Sterben im Mittelmeer zusehen
dass wir weiter diesen brutalen
Darwinismus zusehen dass arme in armen
Ländern der stärkste Heranwachsende
losgeschickt wird das ist doch nicht
richtig das kann doch dauerhaft nicht
richtig sein und nur weil Modelle
noch nicht funktionieren daran zu
arbeiten abzulehnen ist doch nicht ist
doch nicht richtig mich erinnert das
sehr daran was wir 2015 2016 erlebt
haben es waren die gleichen Ratgeber
übrigens die das eutürkei Abkommen uns
angeraten haben da haben auch alle
gesagt das geht doch nicht wie soll das
gehen wie soll so eine Verein ung
Aussehen am Ende war es das einzige das
über Jahre hin tragfähig war und
geholfen hat nein das ist nichts was
über Nacht hilft nein das ist nicht
einfach es ist auch nicht garantiert
dass das gelingt aber die Alternative
ist dem Sterben im Mittelmeer zuzusehen
und alles so laufen zu lassen aber wenn
sie selbst sagen das ist jetzt nichts
für eine Lösung für morgen und solche
Dinge brauchen auch auch Verhandlungen
und und Zeit und das ist schwierig warum
ist denn dann Herr März so negativ
gewesen heute und so offenkundig
frustriert ich glaube da fragen Sie ihn
am am besten selbst aber in Summe sind
wir eben noch nicht da dass wir darauf
vertrauen können dass im nächsten Jahr
wirklich die Zahlen runtergehen es gibt
langfristige Maßnahmen kurzfristige
Maßnahmen eins aber ist völlig klar
unsere Infrastruktur was Flucht und Asyl
angeht ist völlig überlastet die
Kommunen sind überlastet sie haben oft
auch im heute journal Berichte von
Landräten Bürgermeistern
Oberbürgermeistern die ihnen das ja auch
berichten unsere Schulen unsere Kitas
überall Kinder die besondere Förderung
äh brauchen es geht ja um Menschen es
geht übrigens auch auch um Menschen die
das alles umsetzen müssen all das
passiert ja auf dem Rücken von Menschen
von Erzieherinnen Erziehern Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer und deswegen müssen wir
deutlich Tempo machen jetzt auch bei der
Umsetzung des verabredeten und ich sage
voraus wir werden in wenigen Wochen und
Monaten auch über andere Dinge noch
sprechen her wü danke ihn für das
Gespräch danke
Ihnen wie gesagt das Ruanda Modell hat
seine Tücken es gibt zwar unter den
migrationsexperten in der Tat starke
Befürworter und die stehen auch nicht im
Verdacht sich für humanitäre Fragen
nicht zu interessieren im Gegenteil sie
wollen vor allem wie auch Herr wüst eben
sagte dass die schleppergeschäfte und
dass das Sterben auf dem Mittelmeer
aufhört aber ob die praktische Umsetzung
überhaupt gelingen könnte das zu zeigen
das steht noch aus Großbritannien hat
dieses Modell ja quasi aus der Taufe
gehoben gehabt und mit dem Staat Ruanda
gab es ja auch sogar schon eine
Vereinbarung doch sehr weit gekommen ist
man damit bislang nicht berichtet unsere
Korrespondentin Hilke
Petersen sie kommen über den Ärmelkanal
versuchen die englische Südküste zu
erreichen in diesem Jahr schon 27 000
Flüchtlinge in boten die Großbritannien
nicht will die Regierung verfolgt
seither entschlossen ihren Plan will
Flüchtlinge abschrecken mit der Drohung
sie in das ostafrikanische Ruanda
abzuschieben ohne das Recht jemals
wieder einreisen zu dürfen nach
Großbritannien
wir werden neue Gesetze machen um die
kleinen Bote zu stoppen sicherstellen
dass jeder der illegal hierherkommt
festgenommen und schleunigst abgeschoben
wird ankommende Flüchtlinge werden
festgesetzt und inzwischen auch
untergebracht vor der Küste von Dorset
auf einem Frachter wegen Platzmangels in
den Unterkünften und Unmut in der
Bevölkerung rffi der nicht erkannt
werden will ist aus Iran geflüchtet kam
in einem Boot wartet seither auf
Abschiebung in Großbritannien
viele leben seit Jahren hier in diesem
Hotel nichts passiert mit ihnen häufig
haben sie Depressionen weil sie so
darunter leiden dass sie wie ich hier
sitzen denn bisher startete nicht ein
Abschiebeflug Richtung Ruanda im Sommer
vergangenen Jahres stoppte der
Europäische Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte den ersten Versuch
Menschen nach Ruanda zu
fliegen auch britische Richter verbieten
das bisher Randa so das Urteil sei kein
sicheres Land und nicht in der Lage
angemessene Asylverfahren durchzuführen
dabei ist das der zentrale Teil des
britischen Plans nur dann würde er
funktionieren sagen Migrationsforscher
am besten mit Unterstützung vom
unfüchtlingshilfswerk also wir brauchen
fare Behandlung Ausschluss von
unmenschlicher Behandlung das darf keine
Gefahr sein und faere Asylverfahren etwa
durch Einbeziehen des UNHCR dann ist das
mit den Grundrechten den Grund
Konventionen dem was auch in Europa gilt
kompatibel Knaus glaubt dass
Asylbewerber aus europäischer Richtung
nach Afrika geschickt werden könnten
wenn es nun mehrere Staaten in Afrika
gibt die sagen wir wären bereit eine
kleine Zahl von Menschen nach einem
Stichtag aufzunehmen um die tödliche
irreguläre Migration zu reduzieren und
durch legale Migration und Mobilität zu
ersetzen dann halte ich es für fast
rassistisch zu sagen afrikanische Länder
sind dazu nicht in der Lage die
britische Regierung aber scheitert
bisher an ihrem ruandaap auch wenn die
Innenministerin dort bereits eine
Baustelle für Asylbewerber Unterkünfte
besuchte und weiter darauf wartet dass
Sie hierher abschieben
darf und jetzt geht's bei dir erstmal
weiter Heinz mit anderen wichtigen
Nachrichten das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
hat heute über die Klage von
schwerkranken Menschen entschieden die
ein Betäubungsmittel zur Selbsttötung
erwerben wollen es hat wie die
Vorinstanzen die erlaub ist dazu
abgelehnt das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
verweist unter anderem auf die
Schutzwirkung der Verbotsregelung für
das Gemeinwohl die Gefahren eines Miss
oder fehgebrauchs seinen groß die Kläger
wollen Verfassungsbeschwerde in
Karlsruhe
Einlegen in SachsenAnhalt hat der
Verfassungsschutz den Landesverband der
AFD als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft bereits seit 2021 ist der
Landesverband als Verdachtsfall
eingestuft es sein umfangreiche
Informationen gesammelt worden die nicht
mit Menschenwürde Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatsprinzip vereinbar sein so
der
landesverfassungsschutz eine
systematische Beobachtung unter Einsatz
geheimdienstlicher Mittel sei
gerechtfertigt die Bundestagsfraktion
der Linken will nächste Woche ihre
Auflösung beschließen und dann auch den
Zeitpunkt dafür festlegen das kündigte
nach einer Sitzung der Fraktion deren
Vorsitzender Dietmar barartsch an
hintergrund ist der Bruch mit SAR
Wagenknecht und weiter Abgeordneten die
ihren Austritt aus der Linkspartei
erklärt und ein Konkurrenzprojekt
angekündigt haben ohne den für den
fraktionstatus nötige Mindestgröße von
37 Mandaten können die Abgeordneten in
Gruppen weitermachen mit weniger
parlamentarischen
rechten Portugals Ministerpräsident
Kosta ist nach Korruptionsvorwürfen
überraschend zurückgetreten zuvor hatte
die Polizei dessen Residenz sowie zwei
Ministerien und andere Gebäude
durchsucht hinter Grund sind
Ermittlungen im Zusammenhang mit der
Vergabe von abbaulizenzen für Lithium
sowie der Produktion von grünem
Wasserstoff medienberichten zufolge
wurden fünf Personen festgenommen
darunter auch Kostas Stabschef kostter
Versicherte sein Gewissen sei
rein vor dem 85 jahrestag der
antijüdischen prgrome vom 9 November
1938 hat sich der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung Felix Klein bestürzt
über die die aktuelle Lage im Land
geäußert mit Blick auf antisemitische
Vorfälle etwa bei Demonstrationen nach
dem Terrorangriff der islamistischen
Hamas auf Israel sagte Klein in Berlin
was man seit dem 7 Oktober sehe sei
Judenhass auf einem in Deutschland seit
Jahrzehnten nicht mehr daageesenen
Niveau Anlass für die Pressekonferenz
war die Vorstellung eines von der amadeo
Antonio Stiftung erstellten
zivilgesellschaftlichen lagebilds
Antisemitismus und ein Gespräch mit dem
Antisemitismus beauftragten Felix Klein
sehen sie gegen 0:30 Uhr im heute schnal
Update die israelischen Truppen sind
nach Regierungsangaben im Kampf gegen
die Hamas in das Zentrum von gazastadt
eingerückt Ministerpräsident Netanyahu
kündigte an Israel wolle für unbestimmte
Zeit die Verantwortung für die
Sicherheit in Gaza übernehmen man habe
gesehen was passiere wenn Israel sie
nicht habe man habe einen Ausbruch des
hamasterrors in einem Maße gesehen wie
man es sich nicht hätte vorstellen
können auf den Tag ein Monat ist es her
dass Israel von der Hamas überfallen
wurde deren Terroristen mehr als 1400
Menschen töteten vielfach auf
bestialische Art und Weise es gehört zu
den Asymmetrien dieses Krieges dass die
Videos die die Täter dabei drehten nicht
weltweit im Fernsehen gezeigt werden sie
sind praktisch nicht zu ertragen und
viele die sie gesehen hab brauchten
danach psychologische
Unterstützung der zweite Schock lag in
der Verschleppung von mehr als 240
Geiseln darunter Kleinkinder die erst
mit ansehen mussten wie ihre Eltern
ermordet wurden und die seitdem irgendwo
in Gaza festgehalten werden falls sie
noch leben Israels Regierungschef
Netanyahu sagt dass es keine Feuerpause
geben werde bevor die Geisel nicht
freigelassen werden viele Angehörige
fürchten jedoch dass der Krieg die
Entführten erst recht gefährdet henrette
deier berichtet aus Tel
Aviv Israel ist im Krieg doch jardin
kann nur an eines denken die Rückkehr
ihrer Schwester seit ein paar Tagen lebt
jardin nun hier in einem Zelt vor dem
Kunstmuseum telavivs ihre Schwester Romi
in den Händen der
Hamas wir glauben bis Sie nicht zu Hause
sind sind wir nicht zu Hause also sind
wir hier bis sie zurück sind
das so sagt sie ist das wenigste was Sie
tun kann für ihre Schwester und die
anderen
Geiseln sie ist die mittlere Schwester
von uns sie ist wie der Kleber der uns
zusammenhält das war sie schon immer und
jeden Tag fehlt sie uns seit einem
Monat vor nunmehr genau einem Monat war
Romi am 7 Oktober auf dem Nova
Musikfestival tanzen war unbeschwert bis
die Terroristen der
radikalislamistischen Hamas das
friedliche Festival stürmten allein hier
starben mindestens 270 Menschen viele
wurden verschleppt sowie
Romi Romi rief noch bei ihrer Mutter an
ein Telefonat das sie seither immer
wieder
hören
Rumi ri Rumi ich bin bei dir meine Süße
alles wird gut ich bin an deiner Seite
ich bin bei
dir und dann finden die Terroristen der
hamassi und brüllen komm
her meine größte Angst ist dass alle sie
vergessen und sie einfach dort lassen
wissen sie für mich ist das Gefühl so
stark aber ich weiß nicht ob jeder
verstehen kann wie es sich anfühlt die
Schwester einer entführten Frau zu sein
es ist wie ein Horrorfilm aber es ist
meine Realität in der ich jeden Morgen
wach werde und mit der ich abends
schlafen
gehe die Angehörigen der Geiseln wie
jarden haben das Gefühl die Zeit laufe
ihn davon sie Flehen Ihre Liebsten
zurückzuholen ich wünschte dass wir alle
das liebenswerte im anderen sehen und
nicht geblendet sind von Hass und
Lügen Stadtverwaltung telavivs hat ein
Schild aufgestellt der nun neue
offizielle Name des Platzes vor dem
Museum ist Platz der Geiseln und
Vermissten des 7 Oktobers
2023 jardens Adresse bis ihre Schwester
wieder da
ist und dann kommen wir zurück nach
Deutschland Heinz bei dir geht es mit
einem großen Wirtschaftsthema weiter
bundesbauministerin Geiwitz er hofft
sich von der bundländereinigung für
schnellere Plan und
Genehmigungsverfahren mehr Tempo beim
Wohnungsbau bislang verfehlt die
Regierung ja ihr Ziel von jährlich
400000 neu Wohnungen W wie sehen die
Pläne aus für mehr Bautempo also laut
Kanzler Scholz umfasst das Paket rund
100 einzelregelung es betrifft viele
Bereiche Wohnungsbau Autobahnen
Stromtrassen Bahnstrecken sollen
schneller genehmigt werden können dafür
werden Regelungen entrümpelt
Bauvorschriften bundesweit harmonisiert
vieles soll digit isiert werden auch um
Behörden zu entlasten um bauen schneller
einfacher und günstiger zu machen
beispielsweise sollen Windräder ohne
weitere Genehmigung durch neue ersetzt
werden können Dachgeschosse können
leichter ausgebaut werden und
Baugenehmigungen gelten nach Ablauf von
3 Monaten automatisch als erteilt
bauverbände zeigen sich zufrieden
bezeichnen die Pläne als extrem sinnvoll
die neuen Regelungen kommen in einer für
die Branche schwierigen zeitstonniierung
beim Bau haben im Oktober Rekordwerte
erreicht und wie ist die Reaktion von
Umweltverbänden also die haben ganz
große Bedenken Umweltverbände wie der
NABU befürchten es könne auf Kosten der
Natur gehen wenn Regelungen für um
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen und
Artenschutz verändert werden die
Deutsche Umwelthilfe meint hier würden
Umweltstandards zugunsten von
Wirtschaftsinteressen abgesenkt
öffentliche Erörterungstermine würden
eingeschränkt und Rechtswege beschränkt
also von dieser Seite kommt wirklich
viel Kritik malerie Haller vielen
Dank die Industrie in Deutschland hat
sich im September erneut schwach
entwickelt die Gesamtproduktion ging auf
Monatssicht um 1,4% zurück hat das
Statistische Bundesamt errechnet der
vierte monatliche Rückgang infolge laut
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium deuten aber
stabilere Auftragseingänge und
Stimmungsindikatoren auf eine
Bodenbildung im dritten Quartal hin und
auf eine Belebung zum jahreswech
eine Meldung aus der Fußball Champions
League borussia Dortmund hat in der
Gruppenphase 2:0 gegen Newcastle United
gewonnen der britische König Charles II
hat seine erste Thronrede als
Staatsoberhaupt im britischen Parlament
gehalten bei der Zeremonie zur Eröffnung
der Sitzungsperiode verlß er das
Regierungsprogramm für das kommende Jahr
die konservative Regierung will unter
anderem durch
antitabakgesetze künftige Generationen
rauchfrei machen der als umweltschütz
bekannte König stellte auch
Regierungspläne vor nach denen neue Gas
und ölfölder gefördert werden
sollen was ich hier aufbäumt ist das
meist fotografierte Pferd des Universums
der berühmte Pferdekopfnebel gehört zum
Sternbild Orion und liegt schlappe 1400
Lichtjahre von unserer Erde entfernt in
solchen sogenannten Dunkelwolken
entstehen neue Sterne Astronomen
beobachten den Pferdekopf schon lange
sogar schon seit über 100 Jahren und mit
der Entwicklung moderner Teleskope wurde
er auch immer wieder fotografiert aber
ein so scharfes so gutes Bild gab es
bislang noch nie der Fotograf ist erst
seit kurzem im All unterwegs auf einer
Mission die Forscher weltweit fasziniert
elit fotografiert in xen die bislang
unzugänglich waren er wird eine 3dkarte
des Universums erstellen und tief in
dessen Vergangenheit schauen Markus
wolsffer erklärt mehr
darüber allein dieses Foto eine
Revolution für die Astronomie schwärmt
die ESA der persus Galaxienhaufen
fotografiert von der Raumsonde euklit 10
Milliarden Jahre war das Licht unterwegs
bis es uns erreicht hat ein Blick in die
Vergangenheit des Universums jedes
pünktlein ist eine Galaxie wie unsere
Milchstraße mit hunderten Milliarden
Sternen und das zeigt uns wie groß unser
Universum ist und das zeigt uns auch wie
unglaublich viele Galaxien Euklid über
seine sechsjährige Betriebszeit
beobachten wird das Unsichtbare sichtbar
machen und die bisher umfangreichste
3D-Karte des Universums erstellen das
ist Euklids Mission Einsatzort auf
halber Strecke zwischen Erde und Sonne
anderthalb Millionen Kilometer entfernt
von uns dank seines weiten Blickwinkels
kann das Teleskop riesige Teile des
Universums festhalten gestochen scharf
immer auf der Suche die dunklen
Geheimnisse zu
lüften was ist die Natur des dunklen
Universums wir verstehen nur 5% des
Universums also die normale Materie aus
der wir die elektromagnetische Strahlung
sehen aus der wir bestehen Sterne
Galaxien Materialien wie Elemente
tatsächlich 95% sind
unbekannt dunkle Materie und dunkle
Energie sie dominieren die Dynamik des
Universums bleiben sie ein großes Rätsel
so viel weiß die Wissenschaft dunkle
Materie hält Galaxien
zusammen dunkle Energie sorgt dafür dass
sich das Universum insgesamt ausdehnt in
dem Euklid die Form Position und die
Bewegungen der Galaxien beobachtet
hoffen die Forscher zu ergründen wie die
Materie verteilt ist welche
Eigenschaften sie
auszeichnet es ist ein atemberaubender
Ausschnitt des Universums eine
Momentaufnahme in wenigen Stunden
erstellt ein unfassbares Potenzial für
die
Mission bis 2029 soll elid im All
unterwegs sein wenn alles gut geht noch
länger ehfurcht gebietend sein die
spektakulären Bilder heißt es heute bei
der ESA oder anders formuliert unser
Platz im Universum scheint nicht so
bedeutend wie wir es gern
hätten ja die Erkenntnis hat sich bei
der Menschheit nur leider noch nicht
durchgesetzt das war's von uns gleich
geht's hier weiter mit der7 30°
Reportagereihe heute zum Thema Sucht
wenn Medikamente abhängig machen und um
0:30 Uhr gibt's dann unser heute
schournal Update mit Christopher wehmann
bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend undr
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter zwischen
die Tiefs schiebt sich ein Zwischenhoch
das ist dieses Hoch hier das
vorübergehend sich auswirkt auf unser
Wetter und so gibt es trockenes Wetter
und Sonnenschein vor allem südlich der
Donau ansonsten nähert sich hier ein
neues fronensystem und bringt im
Nordwesten dann Regen in der Nacht
gibt's ganz im Norden Schauer und
einzelne Gewitter einzelne Schauer auch
sonst im Land die werden allmählich
weniger und dann wird's trocken in der
Nacht im Süden kllares auf und dort
gehen die Temperaturen auf frostige
Werte zurück bis auf
-1° deutlich milder ganz im Norden bei 8
bis 9° das wäre die Temperatur Spanne ja
und morgen dann südlich der Donau viel
Sonne ansonsten im Nordosten Schauer die
allmählich nach Nordosten hin abziehen
ansonsten kommt aber neuer Regen von
Nordwesten auf dazwischen bleibt es
trocken mit Temperaturen zwischen 7 und
13° in der Südhälfte und 9 bis 12 Graz
nach Norden hin die nächsten Tage es
wird wieder wechselhafter es kommt neuer
Regen auf am Donnerstag der zieht einmal
ostwärts übers Land bei 7 bis 13°
Freitag sind weitere Schauer dabei es
ist ein bisschen kühler bei 6 bis 11°
Samstag sogar bei 5 bis 10° und mit
weiteren Schauern und damit einen
schönen
Abend